tu pense savoir ce qui est réel et ce
qui ne l'est pas
[Musique]
ce qui est lumineux
et ce qui est 100
maintenant on oublie tout ce que tu sais
bien
oui
[Musique]
nous sommes à la recherche d'une sortie
willow
on m'a dit qu'une fois il ya longtemps
vous avez vaincu les forces du mal vous
est le portrait craché de votre mère ou
chers amis je pensais pouvoir empêcher
tout cela j'ai le temps
mon frère qui a été enlevée le monde a
besoin de vous il a besoin de votre
magie suivez-moi
c'est là que nous devons aller au-delà
des confins de notre monde
vers l'inconnu
il faut que tu m'aides comme au bon
vieux temps à chaque course les chevaux
il n'a pas gagné le chaos et une faim de
contes de fées
notre ennemi juré est toujours là bas
rassemblant les forces du mal et les
seuls qui se dressent sur son chemin
c'est nous j'ai l'intention d'en
profiter si tu penses à ce que je pense
moi aussi j'ai un doute énormément
emmenez-le dans ma tante est attaché le
voilà vous voyez bien qu'on est sur la
même longueur d'onde
quand j'étais enfant je jouais aux
sorciers
je visitais des mondes étranges se
chevauchaient des monstres
jamais je n'aurais pensé à le faire
vraiment
mais c'est quoi ça
des trolls alors là je suis vexé
il faut se dépêcher
comment comptes-tu nous parlera
comme la dernière fois
avec mes amis
[Musique]